foreign
New York City Welcome to the Ramsey Show
Hey Thomas Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas to you too Dave thank
you so much hello gentlemen how you
doing great man what's up nothing quick
question first of all I just want to
just watch preface if I think Dave I've
been listening your show for a while and
I really want to thank you for every all
your advice I used to be one of those
people that really just thought about
well yeah I can afford that payment I
you know I can afford that payment and
just all of a sudden I'm just under this
massive amount of debt and after
listening to for a couple months I've
just basically restructured the way I do
everything I'm just you know stop buying
stuff I'm getting my debts paid off I'm
within a couple years I plan to be
completely debt free so thank you very
much for your your advice
um my question my question is I've heard
you talk a little bit about Whole Life
policies now my wife and I right now
have Whole Life policies they're good
until we're 125 years old we have about
1.5 million dollars in coverage cost us
about 680 a month to have that
um and I've heard you sort of say that
you didn't think they were a great
investment but I haven't really heard
you get into any details about why you
think that is so I was wondering if you
could just talk about that a little bit
and you know maybe maybe I'm missing
something and if if I am I'm sure you'll
you'll hit the point okay sure
um well the the overarching
main companies that sell whole life the
numbers break down about like this
per hundred dollars that you pay in
premium
you can buy the same amount of term life
insurance 15-year level term 20-year
level term for about five dollars
got it it's roughly 20 x
okay and uh for the insurance
obviously whole life though has another
component to it the term does not have
you're obviously aware of that you spend
a lot of money on this and that other
component is a cash value buildup
now the cash value buildup is the other
95 dollars out of a hundred dollars
approximately could be 91 dollars could
be whatever but it's somewhere in that
range nationally across the top 10 like
whole life insurance companies it is 95
okay so ninety five dollars going into
cash value five dollars purchases the
same amount of insurance life insurance
now so then the the gripe that those of
us have that hate whole life life
insurance and it's not a mild dislike I
hate it
um is that is that what happens to that
ninety five dollars
and uh in cash value what you will do
and you're well past this but if you
went back and looked at your policy
Pages your cash value build up for the
first three years your savings build up
is zero one hundred percent of the
ninety five dollars goes to fees it's
front loaded as an investment which in
and of itself is not necessarily evil
it's just frowned upon in the financial
planning World by and large
um
the second thing is that once you do
start building it nationally and again
don't know your policy but it's not
going to be substantially different uh
the average rate of return on the 95
dollars if you look at your actual cash
value build up including the three years
of zeros on the front end it ends up
being an average of about 1.2 percent
let's be generous and say it's double
that 2.4 still not a good long-term
investment if I could get 2.4 on my
money market I'd be dancing a jig but uh
but not on my long-term Investments my
long-term Investments need to be north
of 10 to be beating inflation and taxes
and so it's a horrible rate of return on
a long-term investment and those two
things are bad but the the the stake in
the heart of whole life and the reason
the entire financial planning community
that are not in the whole life life
insurance business have abandoned whole
life no one sells this but whole life
insurance agents no one sells it anymore
no traditional financial planner no
smart investor Pro no one in the
financial World sells it the only people
that sell it or whole life agents
they've gone away from it and and this
is the reason once you've paid the extra
95 dollars to build up build up build up
build up and uh on your 680 dollar
premium you you said you had a one point
something million dollar policy one I've
got a million dollars my wife has half a
million and that's our combined premium
is just dating okay so 1.5 million
if you die your wife the beneficiary I
assume would get one million dollars
that's your face
my daughter it doesn't matter if you're
talking about yes yeah whoever the
beneficiaries is going to get the
million dollars right that's what
they're going to get
that's all
right if you have a cash value of 200
000 at 2.4 percent that you put 95
dollars per hundred in to get to 200 000
or to get to a hundred thousand none of
that you so you have a savings account
that for the first three years you put
in there gives you nothing after that it
pays 2.4 percent and when you die they
keep your money
all right which makes it absolutely
horrendous so you're much better off in
many many decades ago the financial
planning Community by and large started
moving towards buying term life
insurance for the five dollars per
hundred and doing almost anything else
with the 95 but over in the investment
world away from the insurance world
you put it in a freaking fruit jar at
least it's there when you die
okay so you said would you would your
advice be to just terminate those
policies and just put and do what you
suggested purchase relatively
inexpensive term Life policies and then
put you know additional money I mean I I
do have Investments I mean I could just
up those Investments I invest into the
directly mostly directly in the S P 500
I've got a 401k exactly so would you get
the term life in place first yeah
exactly get your term in place first
never cancel life insurance until you've
got new in place because we don't want
you to have the proverbial milk truck or
bus in the middle okay between the two
just look at the money I've been
spending over the last five ten years is
just write that off and just start it'll
make you want to throw up yeah yes but
that's that's the case now you will get
you will get your cash value out by
canceling the policies whatever it is
okay that doesn't it doesn't uh it does
not then but you never get both
I understand you never get the insurance
and the Investments and you're always
paying for both and that's the got it
that's the consumer Advocate like us our
reason for hating on these things and
just saying they're absolutely horrible
it's an Antiquated product from the 40s
and 50s that built large buildings in
the skylines of almost every city and uh
and that everyone now has pretty well
moved away from except the companies
with their name on that kind of stuff so
uh anyway okay all of that to say no one
last cat one last part of this
discussion that's worth having because
you're you're obviously doing well
financially and you're you're doing
really good with your analytics on this
the last thing that happens is the the
irony is that we really don't
necessarily need life insurance for our
whole life
right so if you've got two or three
million dollars in your Investments and
zero debt
and the kids are grown and gone
and you die
oh I think your wife will be okay
yeah I was looking at it as like I will
I can I can die broke if I want to and
at least they'll have this much but I
you're right in the sense that I I won't
be able to spend all my money no but if
you put the 95 in a fruit jar You
Wouldn't Die broke right exactly right
okay I'm doing it thank you Dave hey man
thanks for the call wow well great
discussion I thought whole life was
going to be like time shares where it
just kind of dies over time but Tick
Tock has caused a Renaissance of whole
life agents to start their financial
planning influencer careers you're
kidding and so now so they're like whole
life guys that are trying to make it
cool again well they're peddling it
makes their life cool again you've seen
this index universal life infinite
banking Dave the world banking this is
the hack wealthy people don't want you
to infinite banking is back that was a
scam from like 20 years ago well gen Z
is eating it up on on The Tick Tock Dave
oh so yeah it's caused this Resurgence
infinite banking is code for whole life
that sucks bad that's what it is you
know so the infinite banking is you put
so much in the whole life that it starts
to pay its own you borrow money from
yourself Dave it's do you borrow money
from yourself and guess what there's no
taxes on borrowed money well no kidding
doofus there's never been taxed at on
borrowed money you just run over there
and get you a credit card down oh my God
there's no taxes on the debt you dumb
butt of course there's not what I can't
believe infinite banking is being made
Tic Tac just ignore oh my God this Tic
Tac thing is just driving me nuts now
it's Tic Tac according today well here's
the takeaway get term life 10 to 12
times your annual income 15 to 20 years
I bet I could make it on Tic Tac for
sure you can this is this clip is the
start right here oh man